tu m'enverras on verra
bien tu fais quoi tu m'enverras tu
m'enverras tu m'enverras
maman
il est en train de manger
[Musique]
forcément quand on voit ça c'est vrai
qu'on se dit c'est incroyable alors déjà
Lucas comment tu vas bah ça va mais ça
pourrait mieux aller ça pourrait aller
mieux exactement
c'est le 24 janvier dernier
Marilyn qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
il s'est passé que la veille
Luca une altercation à la cantine
d'accord pourquoi alors en fait depuis
le covid il mange par groupe de classe
donc Lucas est en troisième mais donc
l'agresseur est en cinquième
cet enfant a voulu ce jour-là manger
avec le même groupe que Luca sauf qu'il
manquait une place sur la table et en
fait il a demandé à Luca de partir Lucas
a refusé donc il lui a déjà mis une
claque derrière la tête plus des
insultes et il lui a fait donc des
menaces de l'attendre à la sortie du
collège donc moi c'est avec Lucas et on
a il m'en a parlé je lui ai dit bah va
voir un surveillant chose qu'il a fait
déjà le lundi sauf que
l'enfant en question a été ramené avec
sa maman en fait donc rien ne s'est
passé
le mardi donc le lendemain
pas de souci particulier et à 16h
plusieurs camarades viennent trouver
Lucas en lui disant il t'attend à la
sortie du collège donc la rebelote Lucam
me prévient et je lui dis ben il faut
que tu ailles voir pareil un adulte
chose qu'il a fait il adulte lui a dit
bah non regarde hier il s'est rien passé
donc tu peux y aller
sauf que là il est sorti un groupe
d'élèves s'était caché en attendant sa
venue
a prévenu l'agresseur en hurlant son
prénom il y a Luca et donc il s'est
passé ce qui s'est passé sur la vidéo
donc là ce qu'il avait déjà été embêté à
l'école alors Lucas oui dans un autre
collège il a déjà subi du harcèlement
donc il avait changé de collège parce
que là aussi plainte classées sans suite
dans ce collège donc à Saint-Amand pas
de souci particulier depuis
le milieu de sixième tout allait bien
d'accord pas de souci non plus avec cet
enfant
vous connaissiez
ou pas du tout
dans la course croisée mais on se
parlait mais sans plus après il est dans
la classe de mon jeune fils en fait le
petit frère
un Luca après on en fait moi j'en ai
jamais entendu parler plus que ça
alors
quels sont les handicaps de Lucas alors
en fait petit il a eu des troupes de
l'audition il a perdu énormément au
niveau de l'audition donc ça l'a
handicapé en fait dans les
apprentissages du langage l'écriture à
l'école donc du coup c'est resté même
s'il y a eu un suivi
orthophonique etc donc il a été en
classe ULIS toute la primaire et donc en
SEGPA depuis le collège alors donc vous
avez été tout de suite mis au courant de
l'agression de oui parce qu'en fait il y
a trois lycéens qui sont intervenus
à la fin parce que le collège j'ai collé
en fait au lycée donc les lycéens
arrivent après d'accord donc les lycéens
ont été interpellés par tous se raffut
et donc elles ont trouvé Lucas au sol
donc elles l'ont immédiatement
pris mis dans un coin dans l'herbe en
sécurité elles ont appelé effectivement
les pompiers la police et du coup nous
par la même occasion alors quand on vous
a dit ça c'était quoi votre action
on comprend pas elle me dit oui je suis
avec votre fils il a sûrement le nez
cassé il saigne de partout il est
toujours
du nez plus la déviation
nasale déplacée donc il a une opération
entorse des cervicales donc il a eu une
minerve pendant un mois
des blessures un peu partout
et puis les dents qui sont qui sont
touchées il est dans définitive qui
bougent suite au coup porté au visage
psychologiquement ça doit être difficile
c'était ça a été difficile pour Lucas
c'est compliqué parce qu'il est enfin il
est beaucoup dans le déni au début il
disait pas agression il disait bagarre
donc
on lui a expliqué que non c'était pas
une bagarre c'était une agression il a
fait un bilan avec une psychologue et
effectivement il y a un suivi qui est
qui va commencer à partir de début mai
vous nous parliez du petit frère de
Lucas qui est dans la classe de
l'agresseur il était sur place il a tout
vu mais il était complètement tétanisé
il n'a pas pu agir bah en fait il est
sorti en même temps que Luca et Luca
elle lui a dit pareil mon autre fils un
petit gabarit il lui a dit
éloigne-toi parce que sinon ils vont
aussi te frapper donc en fait c'est pour
ça que même sur la vidéo on le voit en
fait derrière et bah il pleure et puis
et puis il peut rien faire quoi il peut
rien faire
il a eu peur pour son frère forcément
oui oui qu'est-ce qui vous a dit son
petit frère après
il a beaucoup pleuré et en même temps il
a eu aussi un sentiment de culpabilité
parce que
alors oui j'ai 12 ans oui je suis un
petit gabarit mais j'ai enfin j'ai rien
pu faire en fait j'ai été spectateur et
il a quand même ça qui le ronge au fond
de lui quand même
le 4 a été voir comme nous l'a dit avait
été voir le surveillant juste avant tu
as prévenu surveillant tu lui as dit
quoi au surveillant
j'étais pas tout seul il y avait deux
caméras de camarades avec moi on a été
voir le surveillant
et
du coup j'avais dit que
ce soir j'allais me faire taper aux
arrêts des cas
du coup bah il m'a dit que il m'a dit
tu m'as dit ça le lendemain le l'homme
oui le la veille et du coup bah
vu qu'il est pas venu la veille et ben
il va pas venir le soir même du coup il
m'a dit que le surveillance pouvait
partir et qu'il était pas là
il y avait pas d'adultes devant les
devant l'école non alors en fait c'est
le problème qui est soulevé déjà depuis
longtemps c'est qu'en fait il y a donc
le collège et le lycée ce grand parking
donc avec les arrêts de cas et en fait
de 17h20 jusqu'à 17h45 tous les enfants
sont en total liberté sans surveillance
d'accord alors
pensez que cette agression elle aurait
pu être évitée
oui si le surveillant avait pris la
peine de l'accompagner jusqu'au jusqu'au
bus alors justement c'est la question
que vous pose qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait ensuite
alors nous le dès le lendemain matin en
fait on s'est rendu au collège
alors ils étaient au courant parce que
la police leur avait envoyé un mail on a
été reçu effectivement par
l'approviseur et la directrice de SEGPA
qui ont été dans le soutien total dès le
départ en fait on s'est senti vraiment
soutenu à ce niveau là
sauf que
après il y a eu deux mois de
l'école à la maison enfin si on peut
appeler ça à l'école depuis alors non
parce qu'en fait c'était 15 jours avant
les vacances d'hiver
la gendarme qui avait pris le dépôt de
plainte nous avait dit bon il reste 15
jours le temps de la procédure
gardez-les à la maison bon de toute
manière le cas étant soin mais donc mon
plus jeune fils gardez-le à la maison
qui puisse se reposer et rester un peu
loin de tout ça
ça a pris un plus de temps du coup
et en fait le collège nous a dit on ne
peut rien faire on ne peut pas
sanctionner deux fois un élève pour la
même chose
donc en parlant
en fait à notre procédure au niveau
judiciaire
pour l'élève là ça a été glissé alors en
fait il y a eu un conseil de discipline
donc vendredi dernier et en fait il a eu
l'exclusion définitive avec sursis ce
qui veut dire qu'en fait c'est dès la
rentrée là le 2 mai il revient et à la
prochaine erreur il est exclut d'accord
donc c'est voilà donc c'est il a pas été
exporte donc c'est rien quoi
donc tu recommences plus et puis tu
restes au lycée et on lui laisse
l'opportunité de faire encore une
connerie en fait exactement est-ce que
vous avez essayé de ce que je faisais la
question que je pose à chaque fois de
prendre contact avec les parents de cet
élève alors en fait le soir de
l'agression la maman nous attendait sur
le parking parce que son fils avait pris
la fuite quand il a entendu que la
police arrivait donc elle est venue
effectivement nous voir nous on ne
savait pas du tout ce qui s'était passé
c'est elle qui nous a dit c'est mon fils
qui a qui a frappé le vôtre
elle voulait me donner son numéro de
téléphone pour prendre des nouvelles
et puis nous c'est vrai qu'après on est
parti à l'hôpital parce que le
comportement
donc là il n'est plus retourné à l'école
il est des scolarité depuis quand alors
ils ont loupé deux mois d'école parce
que les deux les deux bah oui parce que
mon plus jeune fille c'est dans la
classe de la grèceur donc aussi il veut
plus retourner
les deux les deux enfants sont à la
maison
donc ils ont pu reprendre la quinze
jours d'école parce que le collège à
force de menaces justement avec les
médias avocats etc ont mis une mesure
conservatoire en attente du Conseil des
disciplines donc ils ont pu le laisser
chez lui pendant 15 jours l'élève en
question et là il est revenu oui là il
revient donc là les deux enfants sont à
la maison alors là c'est les vacances
et qu'est-ce qui va se passer après les
vacances vous allez les remettre à
l'école où vous allez alors non c'est
hors de question c'est hors de question
donc cet élève sera dans l'école
[Musique]
tu penses qu'il voilà tu penses que il
va recommencer et puis qu'est-ce qu'ils
disent les autres et la vie il faut
savoir que l'agresseur a repris contact
avec mon fils sur Instagram il a insulté
à l'école ça ah si ils ont été prévenus
directement
la gendarmerie et enfin le collège ont
été prévenus le soir même sur le
récidive donc ça veut dire et la mère de
l'enfant aussi bah oui donc alors moi
j'ai contacté la maman comme j'avais son
numéro je lui ai demandé quelle
calme son fils qu'elle ne fasse son fils
ne doit pas rentrer en contact avec le
mien elle m'a répondu oh bah il a dû se
faire pirater il faut pas en rajouter
madame s'il vous plaît
donc là aujourd'hui Luca toi tu veux pas
retourner à l'école donc ça serait quoi
la condition pour qu'il retourne qu'il
soit plus là
ton frère aussi
oui
donc tant qu'il est dans l'école tu veux
pas y retourner
et aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que vous dit
l'établissement parce que ils vous
disent quoi ils vous disent non il faut
qu'il revienne ils vous dise quoi alors
c'est ça qui est important aussi nous il
savait enfin on l'a enfin on les avait
prévenu que on remettrait pas les
enfants si l'agresseur revenait donc ils
étaient au courant
j'ai fait un mail le vendredi qui est
resté sans réponse
et puis c'est vrai que malheureusement
enfin on est obligé
d'en arriver là pour avoir
pour que ça bouge donc on a été quand
même obligé de publier cette vidéo quand
même qui est parce qu'elle date il y a
longtemps vous avez fait cette vidéo
pourquoi pour que ça bouge oui pendant
deux mois voilà on nous a dit non plus
rien faire contre lui la gendarmerie
répond pas au téléphone l'enquête elle
en est où là alors l'enquête il y a un
jugement qui
qui va arriver le 20 juin
donc avec le juge des enfants
on a appris effectivement une avocate
qui est en train de récupérer le dossier
pour pour voir ce qu'on peut faire après
il a 13 ans et demi donc 13 ans et demi
à part des mesures éducatives qui je
l'espère bon l'aider parce que c'est
peut-être ça qui va le sortir de l'eau
le gamin je sais pas excusé
alors c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut
savoir que tous ceux qui a sur la vidéo
sont les les amis de Luca se sont que
quasiment des enfants de la classe de
Luca donc
ils ont eu eux des sanctions des heures
un peu de
prise de conscience où ils ont dû
recopier des textes enfin des choses
comme ça
après je sais qu'il y a une brigade de
la gendarmerie et intervenue dans le
collège justement pour faire un peu une
petite remise au point par rapport au
réseau au fait filmer etc Louka est
revenu à l'école les gamins avaient
encore la vidéo dans les téléphones
tiens est-ce que tu veux voir la vidéo
enfin tu t'es fait défoncer par un plus
petit que toi tu veux que je te casse la
gueule moi aussi enfin bon voilà c'est
très compliqué pour lui de retourner
dans cette école
même si le l'agresseur quitte l'école
c'est ça que je vous posez cette
question alors c'est difficile oui après
il y a quand même des copains tu as
plein de tas d'épote à l'école c'est ça
donc les enfants sur la vidéo eux se
sont excusés par contre ils disent quoi
tes potes à l'école ils disent il faut
que tu reviennes ils disent quoi
il y en a qui il y en a qui sont qui
sont
sont désolés il y en a qui veulent que
je revienne oui forcément
hier j'ai eu un message qui m'a dit
t'inquiète pas tu es fort on t'attend
ça fait du bien ça
à l'école
je sais pas si tu dois leur manquer un
peu quand même
toi ça te manque de retourner à l'école
tu as envie d'y retourner j'ai envie de
revoir tes potes tout ça
mais tu as juste plus envie qu'il soit
dans ton école
sinon tu retourneras jamais
donc il sera là tu retourneras pas
vous avez vous avez informé de
l'établissement que qu'il avait insulté
sur les réseaux oui ils ont fait les
captures d'écran j'ai toujours dit quoi
vous avez pas les voir
on y est allé mais eux ils nous disent
que c'est pas de leur ressort en fait ça
ne les regarde pas
dans l'école c'est la sécurité on est
dans des collèges et des lycées l'autre
fois c'était Farès là c'est ce jeu c'est
un mec de 13 ans et demi qui règne moi
je m'adresse au lycée au collège là je
m'adresse aux responsable les
enseignants par les enseignants mais les
surveillants et le directeur de cette de
ce collège vous avez un cahier de 13 ans
et demi qui tape des gens comme ça
devant le car qui fait le caïd et on a
peur de lui en fait vous avez peur d'un
gamin de 13 ans et demi au lieu de dire
il va pas il va pas venir au car appelle
le mec appelle le mec qui agresse
convoque le dit ne touche pas au car il
y a des menaces sur lui il ne le touche
pas non non tu peux aller au car il est
pas venu hier il viendra pas c'est quoi
ces gens-là eh les gars il y a un enfant
qui est en difficulté qui va se faire
frapper vous vous appelez le mec
l'agresseur vous le convoquez et vous
dites tu le touches pas car tu ne le
touches pas sinon il a 13 ans et demi si
je crois si je résume il commande lui
dans le collège et dans le lycée c'est
lui qui commande en fait fais ce qu'il
veut celui qui commence par la mesure le
20 juin c'est trop tard donc là c'est
quoi alors là vous attend de quoi là
du coup depuis hier
ça a explosé au niveau sur les réseaux
d'accord
le CFA la gendarmerie m'a appelé tout à
l'heure je suis entendue jeudi par
rapport à ça je dois m'expliquer
sur le fait que voilà il y a un
acharnement contre l'agresseur et que
dans contre l'agresseur
voilà donc je suis entendu jeudi
le collège effectivement m'a contacté en
me disant qu'il y avait enfin ils ont
mis en place avec le l'inspection
académique un système d'appel par
rapport à ce conseil de discipline donc
ça va être étudié donc le 10 mai et en
attendant donc l'enfant du 2 mai
jusqu'au 10 est encore en mesure
conservatoire et il faudra attendre en
fait la décision de l'Académie d'Orléans
savoir si l'enfant revient ou pas
on te fait des gros bisous mon chéri on
est avec toi à fond et on espère que tu
vas pouvoir retourner à l'école assez
vite et on va suivre la ferme